avada kadavra confirmed peeves wizard
duels house elves and nearly headless
nick yep multiplayer not happening
quidditch in diagon alley stay tuned all
right harry potter fans hogwarts legacy
is set to release later this year and
it's shaping up to be the boldest
attempt we've ever seen to create a
wizarding world video game that lives up
to the dreams we had as kids of being
able to wander the halls of hogwarts and
learn magic alongside other witches and
wizards now let's get the obvious out of
the way first did you know hogwarts
legacy is not an mmo nor is it expected
to have any form of multiplayer when it
ships later this year nope it's being
developed as a single player open world
action rpg it will release on ps4 ps5
xbox one xbox series s and x pc and even
the nintendo switch which was a surprise
announcement made after the release of
the latest trailer the game is set in
the late 1800s wizarding world of harry
potter thanks to a shot of the daily
prophet in the most recent trailer we
also know our character will start
hogwarts on september 1st 1890 which
puts us attending hogwarts just before
young albus dumbledore's arrival as he
would have only been 9 when our
character starts in 1890. despite being
said in the world of harry potter the
game will tell an original story and
players don't have to be familiar with
the original series although there are
numerous details that are sure to please
longtime fans hogwarts legacy is not a
direct adaptation of the books and films
however the games are anchored in the
wizarding world lore familiar faces like
nearly headless nick peeves the
poltergeist and professor bins are all
set to make an appearance as well as a
professor with the last name of fig
although it's worth noting this fig
spells his last name with only one g
unlike arabella fig of the harry potter
series who spelled her name with 2gs
it's developed by avalanche software
nope not the just cause devs the cars 3
devs and it will be published by wb
under the port key games label which is
a label specifically created for the
wizarding world of harry potter a full
trailer of the game leaked back in 2018
when a reddit user posted it online he
claimed to have been part of a mall
survey group that was shown a trailer
for the game and somehow managed to get
by without signing an nda the game was
finally officially announced at the ps5
showcase event back in 2020 and was set
to release in 2021 before being delayed
it's now scheduled to release around the
2022 holiday season of november and
december avalanche has also done an
incredible job of creating the four
hogwarts common rooms and even in the
limited look we've seen so far their
uniqueness and attention to detail
within each of the common rooms is
evident the hogwarts kitchens are
buzzing with activity house elves
included and the devs even managed to
include the fifth floor prefix bathroom
again with a remarkable attention to
detail as for the main character our
backstory remains shrouded in mystery
we'll start hogwarts as a fifth year
with an unusual ability to manipulate
powerful ancient magic hidden in the
wizarding world the specific ancient
powers we can unlock appear to manifest
in different ways we see two in the
gameplay trailer as the narrator says
you can even use the mysterious powerful
magic your professors do not understand
to obliterate your strongest foes the
powers appear to show up visually with a
sort of blue black and white spell
effect with both a dash and lightning
ability shown here it's also known that
our main character survived something
significant that makes us a bit of a
celebrity when we start off at hogwarts
not unlike harry there's been quite a
bit of discussion about how exactly the
sorting ceremony will work but we do
know that we'll choose our house at the
start of the game again i can't
reiterate this one enough guys it is on
the official website we will choose our
house at the start of the game the devs
have hinted at players meeting up with a
weasley or two throughout the halls of
hogwarts we also know the identity of
one dark wizard here victor rookwood who
is almost certainly an ancestor of
augustus rookwood the rookwood of the
1890s is involved with a goblin by the
name of ranrock who appears to be
organizing a rebellion against wizard
kind there are three npc companions that
have been confirmed so far
onnai a gryffindor with a love for
adventure seeking justice poppy's
sweetie a hufflepuff with a strong
connection to magical beasts and
sebastian sallow a slytherin with a
troubling family secret likely related
to some sort of curse we'll also be
traveling to familiar locations
including the forbidden forest and
hogsmeade village diagon alley has yet
to be confirmed for the game and yes i
know we see all vanders in the trailer
however look closely that's the
hogsmeade branch of the wand shop in the
first official trailer we did see a shot
of dementors in what appears to be
azkaban however this is yet to be
confirmed as a location we'll actually
visit in-game magical creatures will
feature prominently and a number of them
have been confirmed including centaurs
goblins house elves grab horns moon cavs
acromantula floopers nasals trolls
hippogriffs dragons thestrals and even
dementors and inferior speaking of
thestrals our character can see and
interact with them which confirms we had
to have witnessed death at some point
some of the creatures have been
corrupted by an unknown magical force
many of the enemies in the gameplay
trailer have glowing red eyes which is
likely the indication of creatures
corrupted by this dark magic jk rowling
is not directly involved with the
project however hogwarts legacy does
plan to adhere to the wizarding world
lore set forth in the harry potter books
we'll be able to customize our character
and upgrade various talents and
abilities we can also purchase gear and
cosmetics at hogsmeed village and to be
clear that's in-game money as hogwarts
legacy has been confirmed to have no
micro transactions by both the official
website and chandler wood the hogwarts
legacy community manager vendors and
residents will populate the countryside
outside the walls of hogwarts with
unique stories to tell in missions where
they may need our main character's
assistance broomsticks and flying are
shown in the trailer but we still don't
have any confirmation about whether or
not we'll be able to play quidditch in
the game despite several hints in both
trailers specific spells shown in the
trailer include lumos accio reducto
defindo rapero apugno confringo incendio
and guardium leviosa expelliarmus
descendo petrificus totalis stupefy and
yes be careful where you choose to
explore as it may lead you down a darker
path
[Music]
wizard duels are also confirmed and the
game appears to feature quite a robust
spell casting system that allows you to
chain spells together you can brew
potions to aid or even use certain
magical creatures to help when battling
other wizards there's a chance merlin
can play a key role in the game as his
name is seen on the window in the
gameplay trailer here the same trailer
also mentions puzzles designed by merlin
the room of requirement is confirmed to
be in the game and appears to act as a
hub for our character we can brew
potions here and create a menagerie to
neutral magical beasts back to health as
some may be injured thanks to poachers
in the area we can even customize this
space to reflect our personality and
magical specialties the game also
appears to have a clever built-in fast
travel system through the use of various
flue powder stations which you can spot
throughout the gameplay trailer these
stations bear the name of ignatia
wildsmith the witch who invented flu
powder day night cycles are officially
confirmed as are seasonal weather
changes now if you guys are looking for
a much more in-depth breakdown of the
lore we know so far about hogwarts
legacy then check out the video on the
right side of your screen now as always
thank you all so much for watching i'll
talk to you again soon